[Música]
revista de prensa en directo americana
france24 rosa pérez más de conmigo en el
estudio rosa al bloqueo del mar negro
mapeado el impacto de la guerra en
ucrania sobre el sistema de alimentación
mundial vamos a ver esto en un mapa
interactivo en el medio británico the
gardian
buenos días raúl exactamente no cuatro
periodistas de este medio británico
magnet light fuerte y macmillan lo que
hacen es explicar como bien dices a
través de un mapa interactivo cómo y por
qué la guerra en ucrania ha alterado no
de forma tan acusada pues el sistema
mundial de alimentación y es que bueno
por un lado un punto clave básicamente
es el bloqueo del mar negro que está
suponiendo que haya 22 millones de
toneladas de trigo particularmente
estancadas en los puertos ucranianos
algo que afecta sobre todo a la
seguridad alimentaria de medio oriente y
el norte de áfrica pero estas toneladas
bloqueadas digamos en los puertos
ucranianos no sólo impactan al consumo
inmediato de trigo alrededor del mundo
sino que también suponen un problema de
cara la cosecha de este verano porque
básicamente no hay espacio para
almacenar el trigo que se pueda recoger
pues en un futuro próximo pero digamos
como decíamos la cosecha y el consumo de
esta cosecha no sólo se ve amenazada por
el tema de que no haya almacenamiento ni
forma de sacar el grano de ucrania sino
también porque evidentemente la guerra
los combates están afectando a la
producción de trigo tal y como vemos en
este primer mapa que tenemos aquí detrás
massa de un 30 por ciento de las
productos los campos de producción de
trigo de ucrania están afectados por
zonas de combate o zonas ocupadas o
peligrosas por lo tanto se espera que la
producción de este verano de trigo de
ucrania se reduzca en un 30% respecto la
del año pasado no y es que como vemos en
este mapa con distintos colores en
función de la pues del nivel de
producción de trigo en cada una de las
zonas del país pues las zonas más y más
productoras son las del este de ucrania
digamos las más afectadas por la en este
momento y por otro lado rosa como
dijimos son varios mapas vamos a ver 1
segundo que muestra entonces el bloqueo
en el mar negro exacto y aquí vemos que
el mar negro ha ido aumentando su
importancia en términos de región
exportadora y es que como decíamos rusia
y ucrania no sólo conjuntamente suponen
el 30 por ciento de las exportaciones de
trigo a nivel mundial sino también el 75
por ciento de las de aceite de girasol y
el 20% de las de maíz particularmente en
este mapa lo que vemos son las
embarcaciones el tráfico de naves de
mercancías que tenían lugar el 23 de
febrero en el mar negro pues en los
puertos digamos ucranianos y en los
rusos una pues un tráfico que se vio
directamente afectado no pues cuando
empezó la invasión rusa de ucrania y es
que vemos que a partir de marzo y luego
en abril pues se declaró también y se
amplió esta zona de máximo el riesgo
alto peligro que lo que hace es que no
solamente sea más peligroso
a la producción de trigo de ucrania sino
que también es más costoso porque las
naves digamos de mercancía tienen que
pagar unos altos seguros digamos para
sus embarcaciones y su tripulación y
ucrania logrado sacar el 15 por ciento
de su producción de trigo por
ferrocarril pero claro es sólo el 15 por
ciento no resuelve digamos muy levemente
el problema rozar el mapa traigamos las
rutas de exportación que tenían lugar
desde ucrania y rusia exacto con este
tercer mapa entendemos por qué tanto el
norte de áfrica y medio oriente dependen
de las exportaciones de rusia y de
ucrania no porque vemos como del puerto
ucraniano de odessa y desde el ruso de
nuevo es y allá
salen las rutas este es el mapa
siguiente pues atraviesan el bósforo no
por turquía y de ahí desembocan
directamente pues en las mercancías al
mediterráneo desde donde llegan al norte
de áfrica o bien atraviesa en el canal
de suez llegan al mar rojo y desde ahí
pues se desvían hacia la península
arábica hacia el bolso pérsico o
van bajando por la apuesta del este de
áfrica vamos ahora a ver la dependencia
de cada país en términos de
importaciones de trigo desde rusia y
ucrania no rosa exacto por resumir un
poco nos fijamos en el caso de egipto
que es el mayor importador de trigo del
mundo particularmente importa el 82 por
ciento de su trigo y además ahí el pan
es un elemento fundamental de la dieta
pues a de los habitantes no del país así
como de un poco de toda la región de
momento vemos como este país ha podido
paliar la escasez a corto plazo pero las
alternativas son más costosas no como
subsidiar pues los precios del pan o
aumentar la producción interna y también
señalar que naciones unidas pues destaca
cómo esta situación está agravando la
situación alimentaria en siria y en
yemen ambos países en guerra y también
en líbano donde ya el país pues se ve
afectado por una profunda crisis de
financiera cambiamos ahora de
información rosa se imagina lo que las
personas le podrían decir al presidente
de la aimm y putin en este momento por
teléfono pues no y de momento no lo
vamos
raúl porque exactamente dmitri peskov
portavoz del kremlin anunció que se va a
aplazar la emisión televisiva anual en
la que el presidente ruso vladimir putin
responde a los ciudadanos de la
federación rusa que le plantean sus
problemas cotidianos además el portavoz
del kremlin también anunció que los
ciudadanos del donbass de momento no van
a participar en este programa que eso sí
insistió va a tener lugar en algún
momento en un futuro pues más o menos
cercano vamos a ver esas imágenes que
teníamos en la última que fue en el año
2019 antes de la pandemia de kobe 19
seremos nuevos
la revista del preso de una noticia
reportada por el espectador de colombia
exacto y es que el espectador publicó
esta madrugada una comunicado de la
dirección nacional del
en la guerrilla el ejército de
liberación nacional de aquí de colombia
que asegura que es falso que juliana
hernández olivera hubiera desaparecido o
muerto a manos de la ln y es que este ha
sido un episodio muy comentada muy
comentado en esta campaña presidencial
en que pues el candidato rodolfo
hernández dio a conocer que su hija
habría sido pues secuestrada y
supuestamente pues asesinada a manos del
l en algo pues como decimos que esta
guerrilla desmiente en estos momentos
eso si pues en el comunicado la
guerrilla no descarta que otro grupo
criminal se hubiera podido hacer pasar
por ellos en el secuestro puede ser de
la hija adoptiva de este candidato
presidencial rosa muchísimas gracias a
por toda la información en esta revista
de prensa nos vemos mañana con más y
pasamos a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado al día